>> I NEVER USE THIS WORD.
BUT I SAY THAT WAS CRAY.
>> I AM HAVING A LITTLE TROUBLE
WITH THE T.
I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU KNOW HUH
TO FIX IT?
>> USUALLY YOU GET THE REMOTE
AND YOU PRESS ON.
SO EASY.
>> NO.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TV IN CANADA.
>> YEAH, WE HAVE TV'S IN CANADA.
>> I KNOW.
I JUST KIDDING.
JUST KIDDING MAN.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
>> YEAH, I DON'T USE THE WORD
CRAY VERY OFTEN.
I USED IT.
♪ YO, YOU MADE A FOOL OUT OF ME
I USE TO TRUST YOU DOG, NOW YOU
EMBARRASSING ME ♪
♪ YOU SKINNY AS HELL
YOU MAKE ME MAD
♪ ♪
YOUR TATTOOS SUCK ♪
♪ WE USED TO BE BEST FRIEND ♪
♪ NOW WE ARE FOES FOR LIFE ♪
>> WHAT'S UP, LESLIE?
>> HUH?
>> SORRY, I WAS DISTRACTED.
♪ YOU ARE ICING ME ♪
♪ USED TO BE MY BEST FRIEND ♪
♪ I NEVER TRUST YOU ♪
♪ IT'S SOMETHING I SAID ♪
♪ IF NOT THAT'S WHACK ♪
♪ MOST PEOPLE I KNOW THEY WOULD
SAY HI BACK ♪
♪ DAMN ♪
>> HEY, ANY BODY USING THIS
CHAIR?
♪ ACTUALLY I WAS YOU BITCH ♪
♪ IT WAS FOR MY HAT ♪
♪ YOU TOOK IT FROM ME NOW WE
NEVER GOING BACK ♪
♪ I CAN NEVER TRUST YOU ♪
♪ YOU ARE RUINING MY HAT ♪
♪ IF JOSH WAS HERE HE WOULD HAVE
MADE ME LAUGH ♪
♪ HAT ♪
>> HI, THERE.
OH, I ACTUALLY WASN'T DONE.
I SAID I WASN'T DONE.
YOU LOOK [ BLEEP ].
I HAD TEN SIPS LEFT
YOU HAVE BEEN SO DAMN MEAN FOR
I GOT NO FRIENDS AND I GOT
NO WATER AND I LOST MY HAT
DAMN ♪
>> HOW IS IT GOING?
>> FEEL LIKE IT IS GOING GREAT.
>> YOU ARE DOING A GOOD JOB.
♪ I'M DOING GREAT YOU BITCH SAY
THAT AGAIN TO MY FACE SUCK MY ♪
[ BLEEP ]
>> EVERYTHING OKAY?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
EVERYONE IS SO NICE HERE.
YOU KNOW?